Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os hemos hablado
en varios vídeos de cómo Venezuela está
atravesando sus horas más tristes.
Sin embargo, nos faltaba por abordar una de
las consecuencias más graves que está teniendo
el gigantesco fracaso en el que se ha convertido
ya la revolución bolivariana.
Amigos, ya no hay duda, no hay debate, Venezuela
está a la deriva.
Cada día que pasa la vida en este país resulta
más y más difícil.
Y es que, claro,… con índices de violencia,
pobreza e inflación situados entre los más
altos del mundo y con una creciente industria
del narcotráfico y el crimen organizado campando
a sus anchas, son muchos, muchísimos los
venezolanos que ya no encuentran más alternativa
que poner tierra de por medio, es decir, marcharse
y dejar atrás un país que se está viniendo
abajo.
[Normal, ante una situación así, ¿alguno
de vosotros tendría esperanza?
Yo por lo menos trataría de escapar por todos
los medios.
Y eso, precisamente, lo que cada vez más
venezolanos están haciendo, especialmente
los más jóvenes.]
Ahora bien… puede que alguno de vosotros
se esté preguntando, vale, Alberto, pero…
exactamente, ¿De qué magnitudes estamos
hablando?
Pues…fijaos, según cálculos de Naciones
Unidas, desde el año 2014 hasta junio de
2018, alrededor de 2.300.000 venezolanos ya
se han marchado, han abandonado el país.
Y ojo, porque los números, año tras año
no paran de crecer.
En otras palabras, la revolución bolivariana,
se ha convertido en la causa del mayor éxodo
de la historia de Latinoamérica.
Atentos.
(EL ÉXODO)
Las sociedades son entes en constante movimiento.
A lo largo de la historia, ya sea por razones
económicas o políticas, las migraciones
han sido algo constante.
Para lograr vivir mejor, para huir de una
amenaza o simplemente para escapar de unas
condiciones de vida que no son buenas, continuamente
las personas se mueven de un sitio a otro.
Sin embargo, un momento, un éxodo es algo
diferente.
El término éxodo hace referencia a la emigración
masiva de personas que se ven forzadas a dejar
el lugar en el que viven.
Es decir, no se trata de personas que sueñan
con vivir mejor sino que tienen que marcharse
incluso para poder sobrevivir.
Por lo general, a lo largo de la historia
las causas más habituales han sido los motivos
políticos, raciales o religiosos.
Tal vez el tipo de éxodo más repetido a
lo largo de la historia ha sido el de personas
que se vieron obligadas a abandonar sus casas
porque otro grupo más fuerte se había hecho
con el control y los expulsaba de forma violenta.
(Ahí está, por ejemplo, el éxodo del pueblo
armenio en 1915 cuando cientos de miles de
personas se vieron obligadas a escapar del
Imperio Turco, un proceso que más tarde se
ha conocido como el “genocidio armenio”.
Otro caso podría ser el de decenas de miles
de republicanos que ante la amenaza de sufrir
represalias, torturas y condenas de todo tipo
por parte del bando franquista, se vieron
obligados a marcharse de España tras el fin
de la Guerra Civil.
O también lo ocurrido en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial, o con las luchas por la independencia
en países de África y Asia en la década
de los 60.)
Pues bien, en nuestros días hemos tenido
dos casos, dos ejemplos muy claros:
El primero ha sido producto de la Guerra Civil
en Siria que, desde que comenzó en 2011 ha
producido millones de personas desplazadas
dentro y fuera de sus fronteras.
El segundo caso es, precisamente, el de Venezuela.
Y todo apunta a que va a terminar siendo mucho
más grande que el de Siria.
(“En este momento la migración de venezolanos
debe ser calificada como una migración forzada,
pues no se planifica y es por supervivencia.”
Beatriz Borges, directora ejecutiva del Centro
de Justicia y Paz.)
Y es que amigos, es muy importante entender
qué está ocurriendo.
Entender que los cientos y cientos de miles
de venezolanos que están escapando… lo
hacen no por gusto, sino por necesidad.
Y es que, a diferencia de los ejemplos que
hemos visto, el éxodo venezolano no es fruto
de ninguna guerra ni de ninguna ocupación
de alguna fuerza extranjera, sino del hambre,
el miedo y la miseria provocada por la revolución
bolivariana.
(Según la última Encuesta de Condiciones
de Vida, en 2018, el 87% de los venezolanos
viven en condiciones de pobreza, más del
60% en condiciones de pobreza extrema.
Son números propios del África subsahariana.)
Lo paradójico de este caso, es que esta catástrofe
humanitaria se produce en una de las potencias
petroleras más importantes del mundo.
Amigos la situación está empezando a ser
tan grave, que ante la falta de medicamentos
y equipos sanitarios dentro del país, enfermedades
como el sarampión, la tuberculosis o la malaria,
enfermedades que estaban erradicadas en este
país no solo han re-brotado, sino que en
algunos casos se están convirtiendo en auténticas
epidemias.
Y más:
Hay más de 100.000 pacientes con SIDA en
riesgo debido a la falta de acceso a la medicación
necesaria.
United Nations Office for the Coordination
of Humanitarian Affairs)
Y es que claro, la falta de medicamentos tiene
unas consecuencias letales sobre la población.
Pero es no es todo, Venezuela vive un problema
de producción y abastecimiento tan grande
que cada vez resulta más difícil adquirir
productos alimentarios básicos.
Por ejemplo, una lata de atún puede costar
más de un salario mínimo [¡De locos!]
Esto, amigos, es lo que explica que según
datos de Naciones Unidas, mientras Diosdado
Cabello y los demás gerifaltes de este régimen
están gordos de comer Langostas, son ya alrededor
de 1 millón y medio los venezolanos que sufren
desnutrición.
Y luego está la cuestión de la violencia,
que tampoco es ninguna broma.
Las estadísticas de homicidios, por ejemplo,
se encuentran en niveles propios de un país
en guerra civil.
Fijaos.
Y luego por supuesto, los atracos, los saqueos,
las extorsiones y todos los demás delitos
que han hecho de este país un lugar muy peligroso
para vivir.
Y desde luego la policía bolivariana no ayuda.
Atentos.
(“Más del 40% de los delitos de julio fueron
cometidos por funcionarios policiales” Observatorio
Venezolano de la Violencia)
Así que, amigos, con este panorama no nos
puede extrañar que tan solo en los últimos
3 años, 2 millones de venezolanos hayan abandonado
el país por mar, aire y tierra.
(Seguro que todos habéis visto esas enormes
hileras de venezolanos caminando, paso a paso,
hacia la frontera.
Porque, amigos,… los que huyen a pie, que
son la mayoría, a veces toman autobuses,
automoviles, mulas… pero últimamente son
muchos los que se echan a caminar con la meta
de llegar a Colombia, Brasil y Ecuador, en
primer lugar, y luego tal vez, desde allí,
alcanzar Perú, Chile o Argentina.)
Y desde luego no penseis que es un viaje fácil,
para nada.
La travesía es difícil no solo por el cansancio
o por lo que dejan atrás - familias, amigos,
su casa - sino que en muchos casos son víctimas
de estafadores, ladrones, etcétera, etcétera.
Por fortuna, hasta ahora, el resto de países
latinoamericanos han demostrado una gran solidaridad
y han permitido prácticamente sin restricciones
la entrada a cientos de miles de venezolanos.
Sin embargo, amigos, todo esto podría cambiar.
Recibir a tanta gente de golpe no siempre
es fácil, mucho menos si además los receptores
no son países precisamente ricos.
(UNA ENORME PRESIÓN)
Amigos, es verdad.
Algunos países latinoamericanos están empezando
a sentir una enorme presión.
El éxodo de venezolanos es tan grande que
en algunos casos se enfrentan a verdaderos
problemas de capacidad.
Por ejemplo, en la estado fronterizo de Roraima,
en Brasil, el número de venezolanos que asisten
a los centros médicos ha pasado de 700 en
el año 2014 a más de 50.000 en 2017.
Tan solo en los 3 primeros meses de 2018 el
número ha sido de más de 45.000.
(“Cada día pasan 700 u 800 venezolanos
por la frontera y eso está creando muchos
problemas para su vacunación y para la organización.
Michel Temer, Presidente de Brasil)
En Colombia el número de venezolanos supera
ya ampliamente el millón de personas, en
Perú son más de 400.000 y en Ecuador casi
un cuarto de millón.
La ola es tan grande que tan solo en lo que
llevamos de 2018, a Ecuador han llegado más
de 4.000 venezolanos cada día.
Eso sí, muchos de ellos, luego se van a otros
países… países como Chile que en los 6
primeros meses, entre enero y junio ha recibido
a casi 150.000 venezolanos.
Todo esto está provocando que los países
más afectados comiencen a establecer algunas
medidas para reducir todo este enorme caudal
de personas.
(El gobierno de Brasil, por ejemplo, ha anunciado
el despliegue de militares en la frontera
y ha dicho que está estudiando establecer
cupos, es decir, un número máximo de personas
que puedan ingresar al país.
Por su parte Ecuador y Perú han comenzado
a exigir la presentación de pasaportes…
¿Por qué?
Pues porque no es un documento nada fácil
de conseguir en la Venezuela de Nicolás Maduro…
por el laberinto burocrático y por la simple
y pura escasez de papel para expedirlos.)
Bueno, por eso y porque muchos funcionarios
hacen negocio vendiendolos en el mercado negro,
donde un simple pasaporte, cuyo precio oficial
es de apenas 18,86 bolívares soberanos - unos
20 centavos de dólar - puede costar entre
700 y 5.500 dólares… en función de la
prisa que tengas o del dinero del que disponga
el comprador.
(Y para los que tengan la suerte de tener
ya un pasaporte, cuando caduca pueden prorrogar
su vigencia por 2 años más con un sello
- porque otro pasaporte nuevo no te van a
dar - pero este trámite salvo que acudas
al mercado negro… es bastante lento, puede
llevar hasta 3 meses.)
En fin, amigos, así están las cosas.
Por primera vez, América Latina se enfrenta
a un serio problema es sus fronteras.
Y no es un problema fácil.
Por un lado no se puede impedir el paso a
los venezolanos, es una cuestión humanitaria
y todavía hay margen, mucho margen.
Pero es evidente que de seguir así las cosas
serán cada vez más los que traten de escapar
del país… y eso es todo un reto.
Aquí es necesario que todos los países latinoamericanos
trabajen de forma coordinada y reciban el
apoyo de la comunidad internacional.
El pueblo venezolano lo merece.
Eso sí, para ser justos, el esfuerzo y la
solidaridad demostrada por muchos de los países
de la región han sido extraordinarios.
Todo un ejemplo de unidad latina.
Por cierto… un último apunte… Los venezolanos
de a pie no son los únicos que se están
marchando.
En los últimos años, muchos venezolanos
que hicieron fortuna durante todo este oscuro
periodo de la revolución bolivariana, así
como las familias de muchos altos cargos se
han marchado… claro que con la cartera bien
llena.
(“Exministros de Chávez ocultaron 2.000
millones en Andorra”.
El País)
(“El opulento desembarco en España de los
millonarios venezolanos.
Una decena de empresarios y ex altos cargos,
varios de ellos detenidos por corrupción,
han invertido decenas de millones de casas
de lujo y fincas para cacerías.”
El País)
Son entre otros los conocidos como Bolichicos.
Trataremos de hablar de ellos en un futuro
vídeo.
Pero ahora turno para ti, ¿Crees que la comunidad
internacional debe ayudar más al pueblo venezolano?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.